[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous 20h40 on est bien
sûr en direct les chéris et juste après
gros film sur C8 ils m'ont dit je sais
pas ils me l'ont vendu genre c'est un
film de ou je suis pas quoi le jour de
gloire s de la vi ah g Le Fèvre ah
ouais incroyable tu vois je connaissais
pas moi je connaissais pas l'arrivée
directec elle m'a dit ça c'est du lourd
elle m'a dit ils m'ont dit c'est du
lourd le jour de gloire moi je croyais
c'était quand Jean-Michel mer qui trate
l'émission
euh gr j'ai pris une balle perdue comme
ça oui j'ai failli dire g mais en a trop
pris auouri oui c'est vrai c'est vra Kim
Glo est avec nous coucou je sais ton
vrai nom j'ai regardé sur
ah salut
Ginette merci d'être là Kim alors Kim tu
as accouché toi ça y est ça y est tu un
po Chinel dans le tiroir et là c'est bon
j'urais pu me dire que j'ai vite
retrouvé la ligne quandê tuas vite
retrouvé la ligne
merci
Kim donc tuas tu as une Fifi oui euh
elle a un mois ça va tu es contente
ouais c'est le bonheur c'est
vrai tu es en couple toi tu es oui je
savais pas pas trop la la vie des des
Gabes en fait donc ça va ça se passe
bien oui le bonheur absolu je peux pas
être plus heureuse vraiment vrai ouais
et ben tu vas voir tu seras moins
heureuse après ce
débat non alors donc
donc tu as créé un compte insta pour ta
fille qui se rappelle tu peux nous
rappeler Talia Talia avec un contact
pour des contrat publicitaire alors
qu'elle était âée que de 10 jours
pourquo vous l'avez caché elle est
magnifique ma fille c'est une bombe
atomique mais imagineelle est trop belle
tu veux veux qu'on a des tu qu'on aah
oui ma foi c'est une bombe je suis fière
de ma fille mais nous aussi mais c'est
juste on a des consignes tu sais je vous
autorise à montrer ma beauté c'est vrai
oui voors on va on VO
merci fait bien rire de
laortable com j'adore j'adore j'adore
alors la question c'est êtes-vous choqué
pourquoi tu as fait ça alors pourquoi
j'ai fait ça parce que ben déjà comme je
viens de le dire ma fille c'est une
bombe et quand tu allumes la télé que tu
vois des bébés pour des couches je pas
citer les marques ou pour des des des ça
ça choque personne c'est comme ça moi
personnellement je veux le meilleur pour
ma fille et on sait pas de quoi demain
est fait je veux son que son avenir soit
en qu'elle soit en sécurité en fait et
moi je vois pas le mal j'ai pas fait ça
pour prendre des sous pour ma fille j'ai
pas besoin de ça moi je gagne ma vie de
mon côté c'est pour elle pour un con gag
ta vie tu gagnes ta vie correctement
genre combien alors quand même on n pas
là pour parler de ça mais le truc c'est
que mais moi j'ai fait complément
d'enquête hein et d'ailleurs je te
soutiens team Cyril laissez-le
tranquille quoi
ché non mais blague à part je veux dire
moi si ma fille elle fait j'ai créé ça
pour qu'elle ait des contrats pour elle
elle pour son compte en banque pour qu'à
18 ans me dise merci maman c'est pas
pour moi j'ai pas besoin de de ma fille
pour gagner ma vie c'est vraiment pour
elle pour pour une sécurité financière
pour son avenir je ne veux que son
bonheur kou oui alors je ne suis pas
choquée pour moi Kim déjà c'est son
business elle est très d'ca oui on
l'adore c'est son business depuis 15 ans
ça fait 15 ans qu'elle est sur Instagram
sur les réseaux c'est son travail c'est
son ganepin donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
des milieux que certaines personnes
peuvent moins comprendre que d'autres
donc ça je le conçois après là le son
bébé il est tout petit il on le
reconnaît pas dans la rue c'est un petit
bébé j'y vois aucun problème comme elle
a dit ça prépare son avenir et cetera ce
qui peut me me chagriner un petit peu
par la suite c'est quand ton bébé on va
pouvoir le reconnaître dans la rue là il
aura pas choisi ton bébé c'est ça qui
peut un peu me perturber donc pourquoi
pas stopper à un moment donné quand tu
vas commencer à être un petit peu connu
et reconnu pour protéger son intimité et
lui peut-être plus tard en grandissant
il aura le choix de reprendre son RSE
rseau social que tu laisseras ouvert là
je sais en plus que généralement les
gens le créent assez tôt pour pas que le
nom soit pris et qu'il soit usurpé que
justement on te vole des photos et Cera
je te rejoin sur ça c'est que là je me
t'is dit de toute façon ma fille all les
petite je vais voir comment ça se passe
et c'est drôle parce qu'on en a pas
parlé mais je te rejoins là-dessus je
m'étais dit si si tu vois une fois
qu'elle sera reconnaissable je vais voir
et je vais aviser mais en fonction là
j'ai en fait elle est tellement belle je
jure c'est oui auelà même si elle était
moche he comme tous les parents ve le
meilleur pour leurs enfants et moi
vraiment je l'ai fait en toute
bienveillance et avec tout mon amour et
vraiment c'est je vois aucun mal en
ayant fait ça c'est vraiment pour elle
c'est pas pour me faire du fric sur ma
fille mais jamais de la vie ouais qui
c'est qui est choqué là alors Gil ver 12
oui je suis déçu non je suis déç moi je
suis déçu que tu me soutiennes pas ouais
mais je comprends mais moi je suis déçu
plutôt que choqué parce que c'est
dangereux ce que vous faites tout
simplement c'est dangereux mais parce
qu'on est avec des psychopathes en
France on doit plus rien faire c'est
plutôt au psychopathe de c'est pas à
nous tout suite bah tout de suite j'ai
même pas prononcé le mot que vous l'avez
dit les psychopathes les réseaux
pédophiles fait plus rien parce qu'il y
a des gens détqués sur terre oui mais
c'est à eux de se contenir à tous ces
pervers comme comme vous êtes très
intelligente que vous le savez je n'ai
pas compris vos mots quand la petite est
né quand all a né c'était magnifique je
les ai lu bienvenue dans ce monde mon
amour tu es notre plus beau trésor et 10
jours après vous en faites c'est beau ah
c'est beau de l'amour d'une m excuseoi
et moi ça m'a ému jeis un cœur d' vous
m'avez ému et là et là ça me déçoit
parce que vous en faites une activité
mercantile vous dites j'ai pas besoin de
garnir mon compte en banque mais réseau
contrat publicitaire on le voit derrière
Cyril c'estàd que vous en faites une
vous en faites une activité économique
non elle en aura pas besoin
les moi aujourd'hui g je gagne ma vie
mais qu'est-ce que j'en sais que je la
gagnerai dans dans 5 ans dans 2 ans dans
10 ass pour vivre toute une
vie elle pas ass que tu races gnormément
d'Ar bah c moi et tant mieux pour elle
une
vie une petite balle perdue comme ça ça
fait du bien ça fait toujours
plaisir fais gaffe alors je tiens à dire
aussi c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
d'influenceuses qui me contactent
actuellement depuis le complément
d'enquête sachez que il faut arrêter de
m'appeler C mot je suis raide je n'ai
pas d'oseille voilà c'était que des
conneries donc arrêtez par c'est vrai
que tu en fait tu dis que arrêtez avec
ça vous êtes beaucoup plus riche que moi
g combien tu GES combien mais non on
n'est pas là et toi tu gagnes combien
moi on l'a dit vous AZ combien de c'est
des conneries c'est des conneries ce
qu'ils ont dit c'est non mais voilà euh
je je vois ce que tu veux dire mais en
même temps on fait plus rien parce que
le monde est rempli de fou tu vois ce
que je veux dire et moi je trouve c'est
pas con ce qu'elle dit mais c'est jamais
con ce qu'elle dit ben oui bien sûr toi
en Manche non
oui jeanm oui non mais je trouve ça
ahurissant déjà on est en 2024 bientôt
2024 wake up tu vois et voilà les
acteurs les acteurs ment trèsôt leurs
enfants au milieu du cinéma les
chanteurs emmènent leurs enfants au
concert et C ils sont dans milieu du
cinéma elle est influenceuse son enfant
certainement très rapidement confronté
au milieu des influenceurs de la mode
des promotion et et ben je vois pas
problèm mais elle a un Mo et alors
justement elle y a qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle risque et tu dis les
pédophiles et cetera tu crois que les
pédophiles s'attaquent aux gens qui sont
sur les réseaux ils s'attaquent comme ça
malheureusement au hasard de le le
fantas et même si estonnu dans la vie on
dire tu c'est dégueulasse tu as fait une
pub pour les crayons qu couleurs non
mais arrête t conneries c'est quo le
problème50 % 50 % des photos et des
vidéos qui sont sur les sites
pédopnographiques ont été prises sur les
comptes des parents péopil exist avant
les
réseau dit elle a dit un truc vrai elle
a dit à Gill là moi je suis là pour
l'encadrer et la protéger au niveau des
réseaux sociaux moi je préfère Kim qui
le fait ouvertement et qui encadre sa
fille dès la naissance plutôt que de
voir des petits de 10 ans qui ont déjà
tous Instagram TikTok et cetera qui
tombe sur des trucs de dingue tous les
jours des gens à poil de la pornographie
de la violence et ben je préfère qu'elle
crée un compte elle-même et qu'elle le
gère elle-même pour sa propre fille
plutôt que laisser les gosses de 89 ans
à faire des choses eu même d'accord avec
toi c'est de
l'hypocrisiei cette histoire de gars qui
vont aller et c'est de l'hypocrisie
totale il y a tellement de de photos de
trucs on voilà c'est c'est de
l'hypocrisie